هروب متتاليه وازمات انسانيه متشابهه تجعل
عمليه النزوح ضروره وليست خيارا بالنسبه
لكثيرين لينزح قصرا الى المناطق الاكثر
امانا نحو 120 ملايين شخص حول العالم
مستوى قياسي يمثل اكبر قفزه سنويه على
الاطلاق كشفت عنها مفوضيه شؤون اللاجئين
فهذه هي المره الاولى التي تتجاوز فيها
اعداد النازحين قصرا حاجزا المئه مليون
ربما تتذكر قبل عامين فقط او ربما في
العام الماضي عندما اعلنا لاول مره اننا
قد تجاوزنا 100 مليون نازح حسن تمت اضافه
عشره بالمئه اكثر بالفعل الى هذا الرقم
انه ادانه الى حد بعيد لحاله عالمنا
مفوضيه اللاجئين كشفت في تقرير لها ان عدد
النازحين زاد بنحو 19 مليون منذ 2019
ويرجع الامر بصوره اساسيه الى صراع مستمر
في السودان واوكرانيا
فكل شخص من بين كل اربعه وسبعين فردا حول
العالم هو حاليا من النازحين
تعددت اسباب ظاهره النزوح القسري والماساه
واحده فالبعض يهرب من الحروب العدائيه
احيانا ومن الظروف المناخيه احيانا اخرى
لدينا 110 ملايين شخص فرو بسبب الصراع
والاضطهاد والتمييز والعنف وغالبا ما
يختلطون بدوافع اخرى لاسيما تاثير تغير
المناخ المستوى العالمي لنزوح القصر كان
مستقرا على مدار العقدين اللذين سبق
الصراع السوري فقد بلغ عدد النازحين بحسب
تقرير النزوح القسري عند 40 مليون لاجئين
داخليا الا ان المستوى يشهد ارتفاعا سنويا
منذ ذلك الحين لتبقى النزاعات الدوليه هي
المحرك الاساسي لهذه القضايا الانسانيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات